this morning Attorney General Jeff
Sessions will announce new government
tools for the opioid epidemic just this
week New Jersey Governor Chris Christie
who chairs the White House opioid abuse
Commission says the government isn't
putting nearly enough money into the
fight President Trump declared the
epidemic a public health emergency last
month but critics complained that didn't
go far enough because it didn't bring
additional funding in our ongoing series
issues that matter we're taking a closer
look at the opioid epidemic it has taken
more than half a million lives since the
year 2000 retired Navy Admiral sandy
Winnefeld CBS News military and homeland
security analyst is with us at the table
for him this epidemic is very personal
and very painful too he lost his 19 year
old son Jonathan in September to a
fentanyl laced batch of heroin
Jonathan struggled with addiction for
several years and the 1fl family is now
dedicated to studying this problem in
saving other families from the same
heartache Admiral good morning your wife
marries with you this morning in the
green room and she says it's as close to
hell as you can get and the article that
was just released and the Atlantic I
think is so powerful and so personal
because you say that for most people
it's a simple understanding of what we
think opioid addiction is you think it
happens to dysfunctional families with
dysfunctional people and you all were
certainly not that know this this runs
the gamut rich poor black white male
female young old it's impacting every
element of our society and I think the
public is beginning to become aware that
there is an epidemic we need to do a lot
better job of understanding the exact
nature of the epidemic and what it's
going to take - let's talk about
Jonathan because you dropped him off at
school three days later you get the
phone call you guys thought everything
was okay he was getting better tell us a
little bit about his history so John was
a grip is a really good kid well-liked
by all of us teammates his friends and
the like but he grew up with anxiety and
I was mixed misdiagnosed as attention
deficit he was prescribed adderall which
was exactly the wrong thing to do and
that started him down the road to self
medication one of three what I would
call gateway entry points into addiction
one of which would be a physical injury
that gets over prescribed another is
self medication and the third disorder
the party entry John went through 15
months of
inpatient train therapy and did a really
good job he got his emergency medical
technician qualification he was
bright-eyed bushy-tailed ready to go to
school but that that molecule had
burrowed itself deeply into his brain
three days later after dropping him off
you get a call right the worst most
shocking call of my life
we thought he was on such an upward
trajectory he was really excited to be
at school excited to be having his
emergency medical technician
qualification and it fooled us you know
it really fooled us Admiral I'm I'm you
know thank you for your service and all
that you and Mary have done for this
country and then also for sharing this
personal this personal struggle because
I know you're trying to continue your
services country and the people to help
you know one of the interesting things I
found too about your beautiful son
Jonathan too
is this what we're learning about the
brain right and that really struck me
about how highly susceptible the brain
is to dependency and you wrote about
those gateways you talked about him
being prescribed adderall and then using
alcohol to come down from the adderall
and then marijuana what do we know about
marijuana in the brain well there's an
awful lot of research going on right now
about that and there's a certainly
associated a lot of controversies with
that but everything that I've come to
understand is that marijuana doesn't
necessarily cause opioid addiction but
it makes the brain more susceptible to
it more welcoming to the morphine
molecule that burrows itself deeply into
the brain so I think you know they're
important medical uses for both opioids
and marijuana so we need to be cautious
with this but I do think it makes sense
to re-examine the legal age for
marijuana it's much more potent than
when we were growing up as kids we just
we it it really warrants a lot of
research into the impact that it's
having especially on young people so
even if you can get off you whether it's
the alcohol or the drugs that you're
using the brain is constantly craving it
is a lifelong battle and the brain
literally changes and we were able to
watch over 15 months while Jonathan's
brain recovered he turned back into our
son it was remarkable to see he went out
and got his emergency medical technician
qualification
was you know sort of you know touchdown
this kid is back but you said you were
you guys were blinded by the optimism
that you missed the signs of the relapse
what did you miss well we we took him up
to the mountains to a house for the
weekend before he went into school and
he was Restless and sweating and shifty
and we just attributed it to maybe too
high of a dose of medication for his
anxiety and also his nervousness about
going to school because you've just
written this powerful essay about
wanting to help people who had the same
situation he had and when in fact he was
probably experiencing symptoms of
withdrawal because he hadn't had the
drug in a few days because he was with
us and tell us why you think this is a
national security issue it's a national
security issue for a couple of reasons
one cost right there was there's
tremendous medical costs associated with
this there's tremendous loss of
productivity and in the workplace the
original estimate was around 78 billion
dollar a year cost the United States the
White House just recently revised that
to over five hundred billion dollars a
year that sounds to me like it's more
than a public health emergency it's
actually a national emergency and so I
think it's something that is really a
national emergency and needs to be
treated as such needs to be funded as
such and we need to have some very
thoughtful approaches to how we tackle
the problem all of which are very
interrelated you can't do one without
the other or you fail you know Admiral
your piece in the Atlantic was
heartbreaking and I'm struck by what you
wrote about how difficult it was to find
adequate treatment for Jonathan how is
addiction treated in this country what
you learn well there there are a host of
treatment centers all over the country
they all do different things they are
all maybe specialized in one particular
thing the hardest thing for us was to
find a place that would treat the dual
diagnosis of anxiety some sort of mental
illness and addiction those are two
things that have to be treated together
very carefully not every facility does
that and unfortunately our case the
military medical system wouldn't pay for
that how are you able to do this sandy
because this happened in September you
guys just had to go through Thanksgiving
without him christmas is coming how are
you able and why are you doing it a
couple of things you know this is part
of our recovery Jonathan in
this powerful essay he wrote as an
incoming freshman at Denver University
said he wanted to help other people with
this problem so we want to carry his
mission forward if we can we have the
ability to do that we have some very
generous remarkable friends who have
helped us both with the intellectual
piece of this and with the financial
piece of this and we just started a
website up this morning that's called
safe project not us it's in its
embryonic form you won't make a
difference you they were telling me guys
in the green room that Mike Morell and
his wife were one of the first people
that came to you came to your side - I
was where I was rushing back from Boston
to be with Mary and Michael and Mary
Beth generously came right over and took
care Mary we really need friends at a
time like that thank you very much thank
you thank you Sam yes for highlighting
and I you know we have a tradition in
the military of challenge coins okay
instead of doing a prayer card at
Jonathan's funeral we did a challenge
coin for Jonathan I'd like for each of
you - thank you highlighting it thank
you very much take a look at that yeah
thank you so much I know we appreciate
it